[Music]
hello everyone thank you so much for
coming I understand that it's huge
competition here of his lunchtime so we
really appreciate your determination so
this session is going to be about
shielded VMs and I am a product manager
my name is Nelly Nelly Porter and with
me is going to present or present a
little bit later and the Hoenig who is
software developer manager for the team
that developed showed it VMs
so this topic is going to be a little
going a little deeper that everything
that you heard about together with and
he will try to give you a little more
information about what a shielded VMs
are all about and what they trying to do
for you the first and foremost for every
security talks that I've been there is
needs to be slight about our attackers
so we decided do not deviate this rule
and put something that will scare you so
first and foremost I think you all
believe and agree with us that
definitely attackers are becoming much
more advanced and it's really why we
need to ensure that we have protections
against advanced threat and attackers
are usually going after data your data
your users data your resources trying to
ddos you or maybe it's trying to do what
they supposed to do and trying to
accelerate the most important secrecy
you have also sometimes all the time
against attackers is trying to get
credentials and credentials will help
them to get your VM and your resources
and use them and whatever they need to
do and those credentials are really
needs to be really validated so what
we've seen so far that to guard your
data to guard your secrets
trivial tasks and it's more and more
difficult as attack surface becoming
more and more comprehensive and our
attackers also very much understand
cloud and cloud scale and cloud
automation so what we've seen in Swansea
report one of the reports that we
published last year demonstrates that if
any VM started to be available online
literally in 4.6 minutes plus - as this
VM will receive first SSH attempt and
again preferably if it's not really well
protected it can be compromised also any
resources or any credentials that will
be expelled trait that will be used
literally in few minutes so they know
how to do the craft and its really
wiving it to ensure that we are ready
for that you probably all agree that
security good security come from the
layers there is no again defense and
depths it's very common things that
everybody understood and that's really
why we actually started to harden our
system starting from the bottom from the
most games the lowest level we can go
and you probably heard enough today
about Titan but we will repeat again why
and what Titan is providing for us so
Titan is a security chip is it Google
design and Google developed and these
Titan Titan security chip it helped us
to provide very important security
controls for our infrastructure so the
first one that will be applicable to
this talk is machine identity and
machine identity is done by is a virtue
of how we manufacture Titan when we
manufacture Titan the first thing that
we do we have set of keys is that we
infuse in the Titan we burn it into
suffuses so it's they are not
extractable we harvest those keys in our
registry
and also it's Titan registry and we
issue certificates
5:09 certificates to those Titans and
now what happened those Titans can be
challenged or asserted and they can
explain or cryptographically proves that
they have possession of these keys this
Titan identity case so now imagine that
you put this key on the motherboard or
network card and these motherboards you
put in the server now this server can
actually cryptographically proof as the
this error is belong to Google in
standing in the right data center and
provide any capabilities that we expect
from server so we call it machine
identity the second very important
property and controls it Titans offer to
us it's secure boot so secure boot again
probably it's well known standard
concept you probably know about that
it's otherwise he will not come to our
presentation but secure boot is the idea
that every single binary in your boot
sequence needs to be signed by
appropriate authority and if it will
figure out that something is not signed
we will stop your boot and boot of our
system as well also if again the
interesting thing with secure boot are
we trying to provide even more higher
higher security with our secure boot and
what we call this capability it's called
first instruction integrity and despite
of long name it means very simple saying
it means before you execute anything
let's ensure that it was not temporary
so modified and it's what we do this our
former so Titan when you power up your
server is actually validating their own
former it's not trusting itself blindly
and after that it's trying to help to
validate the former of the machine
itself it does it because it has very
important to property first of all
strategic location location location
location
what Titan is it's sitting in between
the flash the transformer and platform
controller hub is it actually reading
this former and the second interesting
properties a Titan has it can keep your
CPU at reset and it means every single
beat that PCH is reading from the flash
is going through the Titan Titan
validated and only after a validation is
complete remove CPU from Ridgid to
release it and now CPU can execute these
instructions so this capability we
called first instruction integrity and
the last one measured boot and measure
boot is the idea that compared to secure
boot it will provide much more detailed
information about what is happening
during boot sequence and measured boot
in our server machines ensures that
kernel binaries that we putting on top
of our former and our bootloader is that
temporaries are not modified while I'm
talking about that today because as you
can imagine after we lay down our kernel
and put in validated our hypervisor KVM
and now we start it again what I mean by
that now you've bring your computer
resources and now when we started you VM
the whole cycle started from beginning
we need to have your former running we
need to ensure that bootloader is here
we need to run the OS the boot sequence
and kernel and all of that has to be
somehow validated and today until
shielded we am show up it was not so
customers asked me I'm product manager
very many times if in yvm somebody
compromised my VM and install some
backdoor how do I know and being very
frank with you you have no idea
literally so what we want to help you to
find this very
rats and from attackers perspectives
they want to compromise UVM they want to
install malware and all as a boot level
and rootkit the malware is it actually
incredibly dangers and there isn't wise
dangerous because its preside below
Vinny's your ass and when you starting
your ass you actually have no idea what
is happening below you and also these
rats are usually persistent between the
boots it means it has very long to lived
cycle and also they undetectable so from
our customers perspectives they're going
to stab those we have tempered VM from
running figure out what is happening
updates and page them help them and
after that reestablished trust with
those VMs and also very importantly all
secrets on those VMs need to be locked
to those VMs or to the environment and
it's very important reason because the
passwords also cane anything of the
value it's usually global secret and
it's softer bearer secret and it means
when attacker will exfiltrate it from
single VM it can apply it through
lateral move to everywhere that you have
and it's really a really bad idea
so what and how we can help you this and
it stood yesterday not today we
introduced public better of shielded VMs
and sure that we amps is a product is it
help to protect against those advanced
read-only your resource compute resource
level we want to provide and be
providing verifiable integrity and
expiration resistance and we offer it
configured by default enabled by default
and free of charge so the questions that
I'm receiving every single time if it's
so great thing why not and the answer is
please use it it's actually a lot of
value for you for our customers so what
can you do with that let me explain you
a little more so be enabled on your VM
they replace your old and rusty bias or
your Master Boot Record and replace it
with unified extended from our
interfaces former as it wonderful it's
very extensible we're trying to not make
it super extensible but the few
extensions are very important and this
extensions is secure boot so the
enabling secure boot similarly to what
we have on our infrastructure for your
VM for specific subsets of Google
curated images in addition to that
before I will go any further in addition
to that we enable virtual trusted
platform module the very long name but
it's crypto engine that very similar to
our Titan but it's virtual device it's
software that everywhere will have their
own and VT PMS or virtual trusted
platform modules can do your crypto
outside of boundary of your VM it means
any vulnerability of your kernel user
mode in you VM will not touch will not
change your cryptographic operation is
that V TPM perform for you and VT PMS
are actually the normal crypto engine it
can generate the keys it can protect the
keys and it can attest the keys that is
coming from these VTP amps and Andy will
talk again in details about what VT
peons can do but one of the most
important features that our customers
like about VT P arms now they don't need
to trust blindly VMs serving amps they
can actually challenge exactly as we
challenge machines and they can say we
to be improved to me is that you
actually part of this VM and what
happening with VT p.m. and it's standard
again TCG trusted computing groups packs
so it's absolutely standard TPM 2.0
interface that we enabled we becoming
TPM vendors as well so TPM pass all
compliant tests
Sochi PM's have very interesting
capabilities they have this master key
it's called endorsement key and we using
our Google CA to issue certificate to
those keys and this keys are actually is
the most important thing because an VTP
arm can attest if you sink for you so if
you will challenge your VM and saying
okay give me your again proves that I
have this VM in addition to the
cryptographic attestation and signature
we're giving you triple information and
it's very important information
it's instanceid it's the project ID and
the zone and then you have cryptographic
proof as it is the V arms that you
really talking to there is no way for
anybody to change it because it's tamper
evident lock that we provide to you as
our attestation statement and it's what
we call strong VM identity based on that
you can decide if you trust this VM to
share your secrets or you are not
trusting it very much the second thing
that we enabled in addition to secure
boot is measurable very similarly to
what we have in our infrastructure level
but in addition to what measure boot
expected to do utilizing this V TPM and
measuring integrity of every single
binaries that we use in our boot
sequence and providing much more detail
information for example because how this
particular measurement is created every
single binary before it's executed in
your pass is hashed and added to the
previous hash of all other binaries that
already have been cached and when you're
going through all of this cycle by the
end of the day you will have this hash
that you can compare with baseline and
be creating this baseline for your first
time ever that we running and starting
this VM and if you'll see that this
runtime calculated attestation is
different from our baseline we sending
all of this information to you so you
can take actions finally it will not be
blind
and if anything will change during this
period of time we sending this
information and you stuck drag our
notification and the alarms and all as a
function you can decide stop immediately
this VM literally stop I need to extract
it and go with forensic to figure out
what is that because out of thousand of
those films one of the integrity failed
not good idea but if you know if you
know that this change is expected
absolutely legit you updated something
you added kernel driver you've done some
things that you understand you have a
way to rebuild this baseline and start
measuring integrity of your boot
sequence and kernel based on this new
baselines that you trusted it's actually
very important when you need to
establish you trust with this VM if the
elf was compromised and you patched it
the question is how to reestablish trust
how to continue trust this machine and
be providing you that and verifiable
integrity you can actually see that and
understand and take actions and VT BMS
have very good opportunity to actually
seal and protect your keys and Andy will
be talking about this in much more
details let me show you a quick demo
and this demo is life as you can see so
everything can be impossible so we're
going to Google Cloud console and as
usually you will start off creating his
instance VM nothing super again
different here you will give the name of
this VM you select so we right now
running better there's this wonderful
checkboxes on track it means you have
both options you can select should each
VM option and unshielded we have option
for every single OS that we support if
we shoot multiple OSS as you can see and
you selected nothing fancy here so you
will notice that we added for this
release sorry let me try it again
yep let's go to for change it show
images lets me pick show that we have
this time and as you can see in Security
tab now all of these capabilities
actually checked in so now you have free
configured secure boot you have V TPM
enabled and you have integrity
monitoring is it also available we make
it such that you would be able up to out
from this if you will decide that you
don't need some of these capabilities or
some backward compatibility issue you
will discover so you absolutely in
control but we highly recommend that you
will not touch it and then create and
you have sure that we have up and
running so but usually our customers do
not create VM by VM by the em they need
thousands within each really massive
production so for that it using usually
using templates so let me show you how
easy is to create template for shielded
VM let's pick windows for this purpose
and again exactly the
experience you have you can opt out from
some of the capabilities click create
you have shielded VM instance template
and all that you need to do the next
step is create a group cluster of the
VMS and regain after I will put this
wonderful name you can specify the
instance instead that you go increase
and it's the instance that we created
literally few seconds ago so from this
moment I have this from 1 to 10
VMs that I can create after I will click
create if I need from 100 mm I can set
it up and it will be out of healing out
of scaling manage group of VM that you
can all of them use as should it really
it's all my demo and can be switched to
the slides please ok moving forward so
we didn't forget about separation of
duties as well because we believe it's
critically important that only and only
a few would be able to modify show that
we have configuration or enable disable
integrity policy integrity functionality
so we added two additional custom
permissions I am permissions that you
can add to custom roles and we also
added this to the different roles we
added to instance admin v1 and secured
admin so if you don't like again our
decision on this I am roles you're more
than welcome to create your custom roles
and go visit so what I want to kind of
sum up for you
that shoot at vm's provide significant
value not because we created it and we
love it but we strongly believe that
it's actually some things that you can
use in take but and benefit from it's
actually reducing the trusted TCB
trusted compute base some things that
you need to worry for your cryptographic
operation it's also removing again any
vulnerability and threads that
Hanan happened in UVM for your crypto it
doesn't have performance implications
sorry it doesn't everybody couldn't
believe me and even my engineering team
but it's actually the reality so it's
very very low latency we will say it's
kind of not equal it does support life
migration and life matchings that all
our customers believe have to be done
and it's Hardware independent we
specifically didn't tight it as pass
through to Titan because otherwise your
life migration will be in trouble and
it's a tested and verifiable if you move
work about integrity monitoring so this
integrity monitoring you can get your
temper evident locks because it's signed
by VT PMS in your stock driver you can
monitor them you can assign the actions
on them and decide what you want to do
so I have one additional demo for you to
explain why it's so important and it's
more recorded because it's difficult to
reproduce the attack but we will try to
again manufacture for you reeled attack
can we switch to my laptop please
okay so let's go this video so you're
booting from your new VM the boot
sequences as you expect candle loaded
everything is fine we calculated it it
crashes we compare it baseline and pass
to use it everything is wonderful so now
if somebody will try to boot from
different boot sequence or even change
the sequence of binaries in your boot
they immediately will find it out and
provide for you two feets all
information about that and very basic
pass or fail indication of that that's
all so can we switch to the slides
please
sorry and now any honing my
partner-in-crime will continue this
presentation the actual security
properties that provides and how it
works and get more into the details so I
have up here the server security model
which is very very vague but basically
you know you've got your operating
system you have your VM and you know
you're worried about compromise you want
to be able to detect and minimize the
damage if you compromise and do that
with a variety of tools you do it with
antivirus you've got audit logging
you've got intrusion detection maybe
some other kind of monitoring there are
things on the operation for privileged
separation but if your attacker and you
want to break into something and stay in
that long term you can lie to all these
things right so our threat model is your
attacker has broken in has root
privileges on your VM so if someone's
root privileges on your VM can you
really trust any of these things up here
if you can't trust the thing down here
so that's what that's really what
shielded VMs is about it's making sure
that once you have this low lower level
and you're certain that this isn't
compromised and this is in good shape
then you can actually have some faith in
the higher level things you have above
that so let's talk about how that works
specifically so here's a kind of example
of secure boot so secure boot spin
around
timeout ten years twenty years something
like that and it's been around the real
hardware world so in real hardware
Microsoft mostly drove it and they got a
key baked into the firmware for a lot of
OAM hardware makers and that key is a
public key and it's baked in the Google
case we control it so we have our key
and a private key is held by Microsoft
or the distribution owners or a bun - or
in our case we have we have a copy for
our container optimized image and the
people who make those images sign those
images so they have their own process
for keeping those keys secure they can
have those keys offline they can be you
know a quorum of three or five people to
do the signing however however secure
they want to keep those keys they can
make those very secure so that public
crypto key is baked into our firmware
then that signs the boot and the
bootloader is signed by that private key
when the Google controller firmware
comes up the first thing it's gonna do
is it's gonna check the cryptographic
signature on that bootloader and if the
signature does not match or if it's
unmodified it won't boot then the
bootloader then checks the signature on
the operating system it's up to the
operating system just how much to
measure there most of the measure of the
entire kernel and the drivers and if
those if those don't match as well so if
an attacker has gone in and he's changed
your kernel drivers which is where you'd
want to change things if you want to lie
to all of your intrusion detection
systems and monitoring systems then
secure boot will fail to do so another
thing that's often confused with it but
totally different is measured boot they
go hand-in-hand
measured boot relies on the virtual TPM
again TPM is a standard that's been
around a long time as Nellie said we are
completely compliant with the spec it's
been around again about 20 years so
measured boot so secure boot solves a
problem that says am I in a state that
has been signed by someone yes or no and
if you ask you can boot if nono measured
boot tries to answer the question of
exactly what state did I boot and it
tries to answer it in a way so that
after you've booted you can ask and be
confident about the answer because you
can have a boot log Windows has a boot
log Linux has a boot log and you know
you'll read that blog but if someone's
broken in your kernel how much trust can
you really put into that but
so TBMs up harbour mechanisms called
platform configuration registers so PCRs
and the property of those is once you
write to them they actually can't be
really can't be zero they can only be
extended so as its as the Google
controlled firmer I was coming up it
reads the bootloader and extends that
into a PC are various other things like
the secure boot configuration or putting
that PC R and then the bootloader then
will then measure that the operating
system and put that in PC R along with a
variety of other things and what that
provides you is if you read those PC
arse later and they match you can be
absolutely sure that someone that it has
come up in the configuration that you
expected if they don't match you don't
know exactly what was wrong you have a
hint because there's different PC arse
for different things but if they do
match you can be absolutely certain
unless someone's broken sha-256 but
that's not very likely that it came up
in that state the other thing that the
GBM has is because the bt APM
participates in the cryptographic
protocol it can remotely prove that to
somebody else so you can remotely prove
to another system that your system came
up in a good and measured state and it
was the right state and in our case you
can you can do the remote out cessation
with the bt p.m. or we actually
short-circuit that to make it easier
because we control the cloud that you're
running on top of to deliver that
straight to you via stack driver as she
showed that integrity in the integrity
monitor in general so bt games as Dailey
was saying I've said they've been around
long time so there's actually quite a
few use cases she talked about sort of
strong integrity she talked about
protecting secrets protecting
cryptographic secrets
there's use cases around tamper-evident
logging and quite a few others I'm
really just gonna talk about the binding
and sealing use case it's one of the
more popular ones it's used pretty
thoroughly in Windows there are some
Linux applications that use it let's say
you have a key and you need to hold onto
that key across reboots because it
encrypts something or it says something
important and you want to keep it around
but you don't want to have it leak
something seems like a pretty common use
case you don't want that you don't want
if someone compromises your VM reads all
your files or if someone gets a backup
of your disk you won't want that key
going out
run around everywhere so that's kind of
what the binding use case is for so
basically you generate your key or you
take your key and you you tell the TPM
bind to this TPM so it will encrypt that
key in such a way that only the TPM can
decrypt it and because the TPM is part
of the hardware that means you have to
be on that machine in our case that
virtual machine to get that key back
that's to bind a use case if some backup
administrator you know let's say you
have a backup minister who takes backup
of your systems tries to connect it to
another VM or tries to exfiltrate that
data and any other way your key is safe
a little bit more advanced is actually
sealing so I talked about measured boot
I talked about how it will measure the
state of your system you can actually
seal a key to that measurement so what
that means is that you take your key the
TPM will encrypt it and it will only
decrypt it later if you booted in the
right state so if you've got some kernel
rootkit in there and someone has changed
their OS system and you try to get that
key out that won't work this is one of
major use cases this is how BitLocker
works so BitLocker says if you turn off
the secure boot features that are part
of this measurement and my system
doesn't come up with those features
enabled you cannot recover your
BitLocker keys for example if you were
to take the entire disk and move it
somewhere else and try to try to decrypt
it you would fail to do though even
though you've got the entire disk
because the blocker key is so now I'm
going to hand it over to Raphael and
Mike from gemalto to talk about some
customer success stories so gemalto we
are a security company from France
maybe my accent told you that and we are
historically providing security for SIM
cards payment cards or identity
documents and we have long we also moved
to services in the cloud for our
customers around digital identity as
well as authentication services and so
we are really moving to the moving to
the cloud it's not an easy an easy ride
and it's a bit like going to the fun
part so to really enjoy it you have to
make sure that you can trust the the
ride and all the partners in the in the
in the fun so we do have solutions to
encrypt at rest the data to protect the
data at rest to protect the data in
transit and really we wanted to go
further and protect it while it's in use
so as we are working with Google and the
numerous topics such as Android security
machine learning we really accepted the
the proposal of nelly to go further and
see what virtual TPM could could provide
us so so why really should we care about
virtual TPM so the first one is that you
can have your data being accessed while
being processed or in memory and we want
that to be protected second is that you
can have some code which is not
permission being executed on your VM and
that's not something I'll show you you
want and finally you have some some code
that can be modified and which leads to
bad execution or also counterproductive
Monsieur in your in your service that
you don't want to see so we did test
thanks to the early access program the
VT p.m. and the shielded VM and here is
our our area let's say high-level
conclusions so first of all it's as
Nellie and Andy shown it's a
straightforward configuration so it was
really very really easy to upgrade our
workload on our machines to be sure that
they would be running using a shielded
OSS so second we have security teams in
France so they played all along the
tried every let's say trixin that they
would know and really every time we were
not able to start any VM that was
attacked either compromise with a
malware and rootkit
either on the Linux or on Windows and
finally most important a that it has a
zero impact on performance and which is
really helping out especially when
scaling down or up so in term of usage
we see two two the first one is really
when related to certification
meaning Zeit for example and the PCI DSS
which is a payment certification for
that we take for our customer if there
is some requirements and the integrity
of the data and on the software so this
is really helping and second we also
have some very sensitive workload we
want to protect
especially around cryptography and
that's what Mike will present you and
all the very quick wins we can get from
shielded VM thank you
[Applause]
so thanks Raphael appreciate so I'm Mike
Chirac I'm in business development and I
kind of want to take this talk towards
more and more practical expression and
what we envision and how we know our
customers are using our products and
what they want out of our products when
they move to clouds in a more virtual
world so Nelly Andy at everybody talked
about how the underlying infrastructure
can be highly secured now in new ways
with great after station so the
hypervisor the VMS but in a shared
responsibility model from a security
perspective you guys also have to
architect up the stack right
so that becomes key management right
that become a secret management it
becomes DevOps security policy access
controls and things like that so for 15
20 years gemalto through our key secure
product has been delivering that on the
on premise side now we have a virtual
edition of key secure and we want to
make sure that that gets deployed in the
most secure fashion on every cloud out
there and Google has offered us an
amazing ability to do that with shielded
VM Ryan and additionally that key secure
whether it's tied back to on-premise
physical key secures or it's just
running native up in the cloud for that
for your cloud applications it tends to
also need a client-side encryption
component that sits on the application
level so to do tokenization of the data
to do data encryption to do file level
encryption to do database encryption
there's oftentimes
a client connector component to the key
manager the using came up to talk back
and forth in a secure fashion and so
having both the application on a trusted
OS on a trusted VM on a trusted
hypervisor privet provides incredible
integrity to our solutions for our
customers things that they could they
could rely on and our hardened appliance
back on their physical data center and
now they can essentially rely on it the
same we're excited about where this is
going and where it can go we're excited
about potentially getting connections to
external HSMs out of our cloud service
or off the customer premise back into
the shield and VM to be a rooted trusts
or to be an encryption key for the
database that's running in the key
management we're excited about
potentially getting custom images being
signed also by Google so not just your
standard OSS but have custom images
available too and we're excited also
about what Google platform security has
announced with the silo and and shielded
containers so a silo is the secure
Enclave open source project that they
announced a couple weeks ago a month ago
and you can see where this goes in this
next iteration of why not just run that
in a completely shielded secure Enclave
alright and so we're gonna continue to
work to make sure that our products are
as secure as possible for you guys and
you can take and bring your own security
develop the same DevOps policies audits
that you're doing on-premise in the
cloud to make it easy for compliance and
make it easy to drag and drop as many
applications as you can on the Google
cloud so thanks and I think we'll pass
it back to Nellie and take questions
from you
[Applause]
in the final words for all of you so
first and foremost Titan is actually
helping us to establish secure
foundation for every single work load
you're bringing to GCP we extending this
route of trust
harder route of trust that we have from
Titans to VTP arms to your computer II
sources and we absolutely excited to ask
you to start using Kyosho that we have
it's in public beta it's available
everywhere our great documentation
website everything ready for you so
please please please start using it
provide us feedback and we are ready to
go and take you to the next level
you
[Music]